[Music]
oh
[Music]
it does seem like the taliban is
starting to gain more power and take
over there
what's the united states government
what's president biden willing to do
after pulling troops out well i would
first say if you take us back to when
the president made this decision
an announcement we he asked his team
to do a clear-eyed assessment not to
sugarcoat it of what the impact could be
of moving withdrawing our troops from
afghanistan
after a 20-year war a war that the
president continues to feel
does not have a military solution what
the president is continuing to press on
is a political
solution and political negotiations and
discussions which we hope will reconvene
soon
[Music]
i can tell you that afghan leaders
civilian and military
were appropriately coordinated with and
briefed about the turnover
of bagram air base
[Music]
you can see now a lot of districts have
surrendered to the taliban even some
afghan forces have fled to tajikistan
and am telling you that afghan forces
will not be able to secure our country
if there will be no foreign support we
will witness once again
civil war here
[Music]
everybody knows we are living in a
country which four decades
four is continuing so in this case
uh some sometimes we go forward some
sometimes
we sit back this is war
in a combat everything is possible
and nothing is stable
it's in the interest of the united
states it's in the interest of
countries in the region to ensure that
the afghan government does not collapse
but we're heading to a pretty dark place
at the moment